[موسيقى]
اطويق صفه لي هذا المظهر التضاريس الجميل
في جزيره العرب واعتبره
العمود الفقري جزيره عشقله في الخريطه
كانه عمود فقري
او طائر فتح صدره في هذا المكان وجناحيه
يفتحان الى الغرب طائر جميل جيولوجيا
كان هناك بحر عظيم
ترسبت فيه الصخور الجيريه ترسبت فيه شعاب
مرجانيه مثل هذه
شعاب مرجان كالتي في البحر الاحمر
وتوجد احافيرها هذه الان لو تمشينا في هذا
المكان وجدنا هذه الصخور المرجانيه دليل
على ماذا على انها بحار ضحله جميله عاشت
فيها شعب المرجانيه قبل 160 مليون سنه
[موسيقى]
الصخور بشكل عام هي هذه جيريه
تتكون كربونات الكالسيوم وفي الكثير من
الاحافير والقواطع ما ذلك
طيب ما الفرق بين هذه الصخره وهذه الصخره
هذه بيضاء وهذه بيضاء
ولكن هذه جيريه لو وضعنا عليها حمض
وجدنا انها تتفاعل مع الحمض اللي هو صخور
طويل
اي نعم
كيف انه يتفاعل معها نعم بدات بينما
هذه لا تطيش هذه رسوبيه كلها رسوبيه لكن
هذه احجار الرمل وهذه احجار جير
[موسيقى]